mais d'abord pour relancer notre débat
politique la nouvelle donne provoquée
par les législatives avec une assemblée
nationale dépourvu de majorité absolue
le sénat espère étendre son influence
américaine
alors que le gouvernement est privé de
majorité à l'assemblée le sénat se
retrouvent au centre du jeu
parlementaire lors de son discours de
politique générale elisabeth borne à
d'ailleurs longuement loué le sens du
compromis de la chambre haute bâtir des
solutions ensemble
en écoutant les propositions de tous en
s'appuyant sur nos territoires en
restant fidèles à nos valeurs c'est la
méthode du sénat depuis longtemps nous
devons nous inspirer de l'expérience et
des pratiques du sénat la première
ministre a promis que davantage de texte
serait examiné en première lecture au
sénat un changement de méthode et de ton
par rapport au quinquennat précédent
jusqu'à présent pas dire que le sénat
recevait beaucoup de compliments de la
part de l'exécutif
c'est une maison où l'exécutif passé
très vite avant de retourner rapidement
à l'assemblée nationale pour faire voter
les textes par la majorité maintenant on
va voir si dans les faits la première
ministre les ministres évidemment vont
au devant des parlementaires les
sénateurs veulent donc juger sur pièce
avec cependant une certitude les
commissions mixtes paritaires ces
réunions entre parlementaires des deux
chambres en cas de désaccord auront
davantage de poids dans cette nouvelle
mandature quand le gouvernement avait
une majorité absolue il pouvait se dire
bon s'il n'y a pas d'accord en
commission mixte paritaire c'est à dire
la réunion de sept députés et de sept
sénateurs et pourrait se dire bon c'est
pas grave
mon texte passera quoi qu'il arrive avec
ma majorité il n'y a plus une majorité
absolue à la semaine nationale est
automatiquement il faudra prendre en
considération les apports les
enrichissements du sénat avec moins de
représentants dans les commissions
mixtes paritaires la majorité
présidentielle devra trouver des
compromis en particulier avec la droite
majoritaire au sénat et qui ont profité
de cette nouvelle donne pour peser sur
l'orientation des réformes à venir
l'actualité politique passée au crible
de nos invités laure salvaing bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directrice générale
de kantar public catherine tricot
bonsoir et bienvenue directrice des
éditions de la revue regards jacques
également denis olivennes bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes patron pressé
céistes et futur présentateur de
l'émission littéraire de public sénat à
la rentrée on en dira peut-être un mot
tient à la fin de ce débat et lætitia
club un éditorialiste politique on sent
laetitia bienvenue à vous le rôle du
sénat pour commencer laure salvaing
est-ce que effectivement vous pensez on
vient de voir ce reportage que cette
nouvelle donne à l'assemblée peut faire
un petit peu basculer le centre de
gravité du parlement vers le sénat il ya
5 6 ans quand on posait la question en
français est ce que le sénat a un rôle
important dans la vie politique
française vous avez près d'un français
sur deux qui considère en effet qu'il
n'avait pas de rôle important les
missions du sénat était pas si clair que
ça mais je crois que à la fois avec
cette nouvelle assemblée et puis aussi
avec le travail que le sénat entrepris
notamment depuis la sphère benalla je
dirais finalement le grand public a le
sentiment que le sénat ait quelque chose
est une institution qui peut compter qui
est peut-être aussi un petit peu décalé
par rapport à l'assemblée nationale et
puis je crois aussi que ça comment dire
ça représente aussi le souhait des
français de travailler de façon plus
collective sénateurs avec des députés
donc c'est fort probable effectivement
que le gouvernement notamment décide en
effet de d'utiliser le sénat aussi pour
pouvoir débattre et trouver des
compromis sur les projets qui va
présenter devant l'assemblée nationale
et effectivement ça vous l'avez ok la
question des commission denquête où les
commissions multiples menées par le
sénat ça a été aussi une arme politique
pour la majorité l ère du sénat pendant
le premier quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
ça peut le rester une certaine façon
catherine tricot à bas tout à fait et on
se souvient que même pendant la campagne
présidentielle il ya eu l'an commission
d' enquête qui avait été conduite par
madame à ça si je me souviens bien sûr
les
lunettes conseil cabinet de conseil et
qui avait quand même un peu embêté la
majorité est donc là aujourd'hui on soit
ce ressurgir une affaire de peut-être de
lien entre le président et puis une
grande entreprise peut être que cette ce
soupçon que on a un patron qui est très
très proche des très très très grande
entreprise internationale
multinationales type general electric
type cdma juste après mes oignons et
lardons il n'y a pas de souci mais on y
reviendra mais j'étais sénat question la
commission d' enquête sur hubert files
elle va se poser exactement et que le
sénat avait mis sur la table déjà sept
cette affaire et qu'elle a mon avis vont
pas se priver de continuer à donner aux
libérations vous y croyez à ça parce
qu'on en entendait patrick kanner le
chef du groupe ps au sénat dit on va
peut-être un peu plus voire un peu mieux
travailler en commission mixte paritaire
qu est
ce que vous pensez que c'est possible et
si oui à quel point ça peut faire
pencher
le second quinquennat d'emmanuel g macro
un peu plus à droite quoi je le crois
parce que je l'espère non pas que
j'espère que le quinquennat bascule à
droite mais je trouve que on est en
train de changer de modèle mme
intelligemment on avait un système
institutionnel bonapartiste hérité d'une
longue tradition
dont et puis on est en train à travers
la la fois ce qui s'est passé lors des
législatives et du coup le rééquilibrage
entre les deux chambres bon
un système dont on dit qu'il était semi
présidentiel est en train de devenir
semi parlementaire donc à l'assemblée il
va falloir trouver des compromis on voit
qu'ils ont pas encore l'habitude et que
la culture du compromis c'est clair et
n'est pas encore entré dans les esprits
des parlementaires mais bon a promis
sanitaire il n'y a pas de majorité
absolue et il va qu'on trouve des
compromis aussi dans le bicamérisme
enfin entre les deux chambres et tout ça
est plutôt mieux qu'avant c'est c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que fonctionne
beaucoup de nos démocraties d'europe du
nord de nos voisins avec des résultats
qui sont quand même plus probant que
nous en terme de fabrication de
consensus de dégâts est d'arriver à
dégager l'intérêt général plutôt que là
la bataille politique d'opposition à
laquelle nous sommes habitués nous donc
au début c'était un peu compliqué il
faut qu'on apprenne à vivre avec ce
machin là mais si on s'y habitue à mon
avis on n'a que deux des bienfaits en
tirer parce que au lieu des
affrontements idéologiques qui sont
notre lot commun on va trouver plus de
pragmatisme comme certains de nos
voisins oui mais alors peut-être lors
samba avec un décalage en tout cas c'est
ce qu'on ressent là on est au tout début
de cette nouvelle mandature donc bon un
décalage qui est marquant dans
l'attitude entre ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée est ce qu'on
imagine vivre parce qu'on n'est pas
encore au sénat dans quelques jours tout
à fait je pense que ça peut même être
perturbant pour l'opinion se dire mais
c'est le parlement mais d'un côté on
s'invective de l'autre on on peut
essayer de travailler ensemble oui et
d'ailleurs je pense que dans l'image des
français les sénateurs
ont plutôt une bonne image quand une
image deux hommes et femmes politiques
posés d'expérience se sent un peu les
sages de
de ce système parlementaire en fait
quelque part est effectivement comme
vous le dites depuis quelques jours on à
avoir une assemblée nationale qui est
assez dissiper avec début des débats qui
parfois bas frise la cour d'école et ça
je crois franchement que les français ne
voulaient pas justement de ça et veulent
plutôt de la construction et du travail
en collectif et peut-être
qu'effectivement justement apprendre
d'eux des pratiques du sénat et des
pratiques notamment collégiale du sénat
fera beaucoup de bien à l'assemblée
nationale donc ça va un petit peu
rééquilibré aussi les choses dans la
façon de faire la politique métis il ya
un sénateur qui retient qui a retenu
votre attention c'est claude malhuret
oui c'est le barack obama des sénateurs
c'est celui l'homme d'état qui
finalement sort du lot grâce à un style
incomparable une verbe une audace et je
vais vous dire une liberté dont un qui
pourrait totalement changer l'image
parfois quand même poussiéreuse un de la
chambre haute claude malhuret sénateur
de l'allier multipliant les discours
sans concession quitte parfois à choquer
la doxa molle et aussi un peu lâche du
monde politique on va écouter un extrait
d'une de ses dernières prises de paroles
c'était la semaine dernière dans sa
ligne de mire jean luc mélenchon et
marine le pen peut-être un peu la yvette
horner de la politique
son blog
son blog comporte une liste de 180 m
arrange et par mots clés
démocratie n'y figure pas
avec les phares en appui de pas mal de
médias prosterner comme des lapins dans
les phares il s'est décrétée premier
ministre le plus cocasse et que certains
l'ont cru après tout dans l' empire
romain on a bien nommé un cheval consul
à ma droite l'héritière du château de
montretout que ça n'empêche pas de
parler au nom du peuple à une stratégie
plus intelligente donc plus dangereux
oubliez le père le pen qui n'a réussi
par ses outrances qu'à devenir le
maréchal pétrin depuis deux mois le mot
d'ordre c'est pas de vagues c'est bien
simple maintenant quand elle passe à la
télé sourire jusqu'aux oreilles pas mois
par mois sourire jusqu'aux oreilles
dents blanches haleine fraîche et tout
le monde il est beau tout le monde il
est gentil
on croirait voir le canut et
alors le canut et c'est marine le pen et
yvette horner de la politique vous
l'avez compris c'était jean luc
mélenchon donc l'art oratoire de claude
malhuret repose aussi on a tous entendu
sur cet humour parfois corrosif un
cinglant il bouscule finalement la
langue politique c'est pourquoi on
retient à chaque fois ses prises de
parole parce qu il atomise est la langue
de bois sans jamais sombrer dans la
vulgarité c'est un ancien médecin et qui
a créé d'octo simo qui a été président
de médecins sans frontières et c'est
vrai que les projecteurs médiatiques ont
commencé à être braqués sur lui pendant
la crise d'une qu'ovide avec des prises
de paroles là encore qui sortait
totalement deux un peu la logorrhée dont
on est habitués en politique et il a
notamment fustigé les antilles vax et
les hommes et les femmes politiques qui
les instrumentalisent et on va écouter
sans discours un extrait son discours le
11 janvier 2022 pour défendre le pass
vaccinale
92% des français l'ont compris par les
anti pacs depuis un an il nous tanne
avec leur convaincre plutôt que
contraindre nous disent de faire de la
pédagogie de ne pas stigmatiser qui
stigmatisent tous les autres il faudra
bientôt vacciner en cachette et raser
les murs pour ne pas les déranger
eh bien nous ne l'ont pas raser les murs
nous allons répond est d'abord aux
politiciens aux abois qui essaient de se
refaire la cerise on philosophe de
comptoir qui confondent liberté et
irresponsabilité aux agités du télé
bocal qui crient à la démocratie bafouée
l'est filippo asselineau le pen dupont
aignan ou mélenchon ce pacte
germano-soviétique de la désinformation
ont traité
ont été successivement pour la
chloroquine contre le vaccin contre le
bas sanitaires et maintenant contre le
pass vaccinale avec une infaillibilité
absolue dans l'ameublement alors je
parlais de savères mais il ya aussi ce
courage politique de poser et de dire
effectivement ce qu'il pense claude
malhuret il me semble que il fait de
chacune de ses prises de parole un
happening et qui pourrait être un des
personnages pivots du quinquennat qui va
nous intéresser pendant cinq ans allez
un mot sur claude mailhot et peut-être
avec vous denis olivennes est ce que
finalement cette liberté j'entends ce
que dit laetitia mais ne limite pas son
pouvoir d'influencé ce que veut dire je
suis un peu ccc il est maintenant il est
devenu célèbre pour ses philippiques
mais ce qu'au delà des au delà de ce
talent à toi est ce que c'est ce que sa
voix pop moi je le trouve très drôle
j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'intérêt pour
ses références sont tout de même un peu
ch ran l'ip et horner lequel la foi qui
rafraîchit son répertoire de l'image
mais au-delà de ça on le parcours du
personnage est assez amusant il a
commencé au ps où il a créé en effet
médecins sans frontières s'est dit de
son élection à la présidence de médecins
sans frontières qu'aux dates le départ
de kouchner qui avait fondé médecins
sans frontières pour créer médecins du
monde dont il sait qu'il vient de
l'extrême gauche en du cadre de l'année
de la wii de la gauche disons rocard
viennent et puis il a finalement soutenu
giscard donc il appartient à ce corps
central
centre gauche au centre droit des gens
qui sont beaucoup moins bons mots qu'on
ne l'imaginé et
et qui sont capables de semer
qui sont capables de secouer le cocotier
précisément parce qu'il refuse que je
trouve sympathique en lui c'est qu'il
refuse esprit de parti le sectarisme et
qui essaie de porter une voix de
raisonnable contre les populismes et ça
c'est plutôt simple et t4 entre cause
humaine je le fait de mettre dans le
même panier si j'ose dire jean luc
mélenchon et marine le pen non ça ça me
plaît pas du tout mais ce que je voulais
souligner c'était que juste avant on
était en train de louer les capacités du
sénat faire des compromis et c est qu en
fait celui qui accroche notre oreille
c'est celui qui fait de la politique de
l'idéologie est ce qu'en fait malgré une
parle de politique les idéologies et
donc moi je suis pas tout à fait
certaine que nous allons vers etc on
aspire tous à une dépolitisation des
idéologisation de nos débats je crois
qu'au contraire le fait qu'ils aient
trois blocs déjà on a pu le bloc gauche
droite ce qui fait que c'est quand même
compliqué de se repositionner on a trois
blocs et je crois qu'au contraire ce qui
est en train de se reconstruire c'est
une identification de ces trois blocs
c'est ça qui se joue en ce moment au
sénat et à l'assemblée nationale allez
on parle pas forcément juste ans et pas
forcément là désidéologisation c'est la
capacité de passer des compromis entre
des forces politiques qui sont très
identifié mais qui peuvent malgré leurs
différends trouvait à tel ou tel moment
d'intérêt général comme en sicile 16ème
chacun oui on va alors par roland sein
des peuples qu'on en avait en effet tout
un débat en comparant ce qui se passe
ici avec des exemples étrangers
l'allemagne l'italie l'espagne on
la question c'est est ce qu'on ne tombe
pas parfois dans le plus petit des
dénominateurs communs effectivement en
gommant les idéologies ça peut être un
sacré charisme et bref j'ai pas envie de
relancer ce débat donc je reprends la
main parce que le fait politique de
cette journée c'est la réponse des mêmes
macron aux accusations du consortium
international des journalistes
d'investigation
sur l'entrée d'hubert sur le marché
français quand il était ministre de
l'économie un président offensif il ne
regrette rien au contraire écoutez j'ai
été ministre donc le ministre que je
suis a fait son travail
mais simplement on introduit une espèce
de d'ambiance que ce serait dire que
voir des chefs d'entreprise particuliers
étrangers ne seraient mal mais je
l'assumé à fond et en vous regardant
j'ai vu des chefs d'entreprise étrangers
laurent
je les ai vu ça a toujours été officiel
avec des collaborateurs
j'en suis fier si l'on crée des emplois
en france j'y suis je suis hyper fier de
cela et vous savez quoi je leur ferai
demain et après demain on est pas on n'a
pas osé on a pas mille à la fin enfin
oreilles on aurait pu on aurait dû donc
il reprend ici de jacques chirac en
disant je reprends l'expression de
jacques chirac ça ça m'en touche une
sans faire bouger l'autre bref il ya à
la fois la défense sur le fond et puis
cette petite référence à jacques chirac
je vous propose de commencer sur le fond
laure salvaing comment vous l'analysez
cette réponse demain sur le fond
effectivement je pense que lui il reste
droit dans ses bottes c'est à dire il ya
le sentiment effectivement d'avoir fait
son job en tant que ministre de
l'économie je pense aussi que il il est
toujours dans cette lignée d'apparaître
comme un homme politique nouveau qui
fait des choses un petit peu décalé un
petit peu différente parce que aussi on
est face à une france qui par moment
peut paraître assez sclérosé et vous
voyez
j'écoutais un
reportage ce matin justement sur le
patron du bar qui disait pourquoi j'ai
créé hubert c'est parce qu'un jour
j'étais à paris à quatre heures du matin
et fiq j'étais tout seul comme ça je
cherche à rentrer chez moi et je
n'arrivais pas à trouver un taxi combien
de fois moi je sais ça m'est arrivé
aussi d'être à quatre heures du matin
dans la rue et a pas trouvé donc quelque
part ça répondait à un besoin aussi
vraiment de la population de de trouver
un nouveau service que juste services
des taxis donc en fait emmanuel macron
en tout cas sur le fond
la même ligne que celle qu'il tient
depuis depuis le départ c'est à dire au
poste où je suis j'essaie de trouver des
solutions pour améliorer la vie des
français après sur la forme c'est un
petit peu différent mais peut-être qu'on
en parle on en parlera juste après
j'aurai vraiment vous entendre d'abord
sur le fond de nuit olivennes
même s'ils assument ce n'est pas une
surprise non et pour moi il ya trois
questions dans ce sujet il ya est-ce
qu'il est cohérent qu emmanuel macron et
défendu hubert oui il s'inscrivait dans
la lignée
ra de la libéralisation dont il avait
fait ça ouvre sa doctrine
depuis le rapport ufa rarement des
années 60 jusqu'à la commission attali
tout le monde a tapé à tort ou à raison
d'ailleurs sur le monopole des taxis et
il ya eu en effet un mouvement de
libéralisation qui a permis de chars
arrivée hubert amazon des libéraux et
donc d'améliorer
entre guillemets le service rendu aux
consommateurs
et d'ailleurs on consomme tous d hubert
on utilise tous amazon parce que les
magasins et probablement pas plus petit
et libéraux ma gueule exploitation sans
doute des gens que qu'elle emploie donc
il s'inscrit de manière ce soit sur la
doctrine des manuels macro on n'est pas
surpris qu'il ait défendu hubert ça
s'inscrit tout à fait dans la lignée de
ce pourquoi très publiquement ils
avaient pris position et il leur dit
ensuite il ya une deuxième question est
ce qu'il l'a fait de manière
transparente
est-ce qu'il l'a fait de manière
transparente et a aucun sujet à recevoir
des chefs d'entreprise mais il ya
maintenant depuis maintenant une dizaine
d'années une rue non une règle qui
s'impose dans la plupart des pays qui
est il faut qu'on sache quels sont les
mieux équipés pour qu'on sache qui ce
que vous faites pour qu'on sache d'où
vous parlez et apparemment on savait pas
tout exactement françois hollande n'a
pas dit qu'ils n'étaient pas au courant
de ces rendez-vous bernard cazeneuve a
dit qu'il avait réservé sa réponse
devant une commission denquête donc un
sujet il ya aucun problème pour moi à ce
qu emmanuel macron miniser finances se
fasse que l'avocate de dubert en
revanche est un problème si on ne sait
pas et puis une troisième question c'est
est-ce qu'il a raison de défendre le
bien est ce qu'au fond
[Musique]
l'affection on a tous eu un mot n'est
pour la libéralisation et l'ubs et
risation de l'économie est ce que c'est
si profitable que ça alors je devrai
l'arrêt des économies aujourd'hui on
peut dire on peut peut-être dire non à
l'époque ça et c'était plus partagés les
économistes aujourd'hui sont assez même
des économistes qui sont pour la
libéralisation sont assez partagés parce
qu'ils se disent d'un côté c'est vrai
que
on a amélioré le service du consommateur
c'est sûr aujourd'hui les les compagnies
de taxi sont beaucoup plus aimable avec
leurs clients qu'elles ne l'étaient
avant hubert ça a beaucoup changé c'est
clair que l'effet de la concurrence est
positive mais le côté on n'est pas sûr
que du point de vue de l'emploi ce soit
positif
on n'est pas sûr que du point de vue de
la condition salariale soit positif il
ya en fait il ya deux types d'innovation
il ya des innovations qui crée de la
productivité qui crée de la croissance
qui crée de la richesse et puis à des
innovations comme celle d'hubert qui
sont en crise que zep téléphonistes
appelle les innovations chaud chaud on
fait la même chose autrement
et ça on n'est pas sûr qu'à la fin ce
soit si positif que ça effectivement
voilà une addition salariale et pour
l'économie en général de la question
d'un nouveau look punk prolétariat qui a
été créée par par cette utilisation
comment vous l'analysez 7,7 défense des
macros ombre d'abord ce serait sa
défense elle n'est pas sur le fond il
dit j'ai rencontré des patrons et
j'assume c'est ils nous racontent et
lydie il dit en tant que ministre de
l'économie ses numéros de favoriser
l'emploi donc c'est un peu sur le futur
maman enfin pour moi non parce que qui
peut croire qu'un ministre de l'économie
et des finances en france ne rencontre
pas des patrons tout le monde sait
qu'ils rencontrent des mettront là n'est
pas le sujet mais il a rencontré des
patrons et il a promu une politique
contraire aux orientations de ceux du
gouvernement auquel il appartenait donc
ça c'est quand même une première
question c'est dire qu'il a agi comme un
free bustier c'est à dire qu'il a agi
pour les intérêts de hubert contre
l'orientation politique du gouvernement
dans lequel était ça c'est le premier
point on revient sur la transparence oui
messieurs laissez pas simplement une
transparence ce que je veux dire c'est
comme la ferme hacking c'est ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'on ce dont on se rend
compte c'est que à quoi ce style acquis
certes il sert c'est pas simplement
qu'il n'est pas transparent c'est que sa
politique qu'ils l'annoncent comme étant
par exemple au service des jeunes
garçons des banlieues qui trouvent pas
de boulot mais est ce que c'est de ça
dont il est question véritablement est
ce que c'est ça le coeur de son de son
de son logiciel de sa préoccupation
encore une fois general electric
mckinsey hubert ça commence à faire un
peu système d'un monsieur qui met son
pouvoir
deux ministres des finances plus de
président de la république au service de
grandes entreprises et je relève qu'
aujourd'hui au parlement européen a été
porté une loi pour pro avoir une presse
son de salariat pour tous ses salariés
dans fait tousser saison toyer des auto
entrepreneurs des plateformes qui est-ce
qui s'y opposa mais qui s'opposaient en
europe et quel est le gouvernement qui
s'y opposent c'est le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron c'est à dire qu'il nous
a raconté en 2017 moi je suis le
candidat de l'émancipation je vais vous
permettre d'être des auto entrepreneurs
est en fait ces gens qui aujourd'hui
gagne 590 euros en moyenne par mois sans
aucune protection sociale pas de
couverture chômage pas de couverture
maladie pas de retraite il interdit que
ces plateformes la l'hérault salary
c'est-à-dire leur offre une protection
sociale donc il ya quand même une
question de à qui sert emmanuel macron s
qui sert la france s qui cerne les
salariés s qui sert les gars des
banlieues où est-ce qu'ils servent
mckinsey une berre et general electric
la mienne deux observations la première
si vous le faites un procès d'intention
confondues père comme beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs à l'époque c'était vraiment
pas ce qu'il pensait j'imagine
un corps de doctrine qui disaient ces
innovations vont améliorer la croissance
améliorer l'emploi faire sauter des
barrières réglementaires qui sont
malthusienne donc il y avait il y avait
quand on dit non mais quand vous dites
qui fait ça pour soutien des intérêts
des grandes entreprises non ça c'est un
procès d'intention qui fait ça parce que
comme beaucoup de gens comme beaucoup de
libéraux il pense que la libération de
l'économie
a des bienfaits collectif la deuxième
station je voulais faire c'est on serait
d'autant plus à l'aise pour contester
cette selon mme peine prolétariat comme
vous disiez cette destruction de la
condition salariale a traversé cesser
ces nouveaux contrats qui ne sut qui ne
sont pas des contrats de travail et qui
exploitent des ddd jeu des travailleurs
si on était un ardent partisan de la
baisse du coût du travail de la
redistribution des charges sociales
entre le capital et le travail si on
était un ardent partisan du
développement du travail mais on est
dans un pays dans lequel le travail est
inhibée par le cou qui pèsent sur lui
voilà pourquoi on invente des mécaniques
tordu et qui sont très dangereuses pour
le salariat à travers ces nouveaux
contrats on serait bien inspiré en de
lutter à la fois contre ces nouveaux
contrats et d'un autre côté de se poser
la question de savoir pourquoi est-ce
qu'on freine le développement du travail
quel est le salaire médian en france
c'est
bien mais c'est bien moi c'est de ça
dont je passais a calé salaire médian en
france ses 1700 euros ça veut dire que
la moitié des français gagnent moins de
1700 euros et il n'y a quasiment pas de
charges sociales sur la tranche qui va
jusqu au smic ça veut dire que là ça
veut dire que les charges sociales sont
très faibles très très faible sur les la
majorité des salariés on peut pas dire
que le coût du travail soient élevés en
france en revanche ce qui coûte très
très cher c'est le tout petit haut c'est
à dire parce que en effet pendant ce
temps là il ya quand même une hiérarchie
des salaires qu'ils aient explosé en
france avec des salariés qui sont
extrêmement bien payé voir des
actionnaires qui sont sûr extrêmement
bien payé donc moi je vais bien qu'on
explique quand tu travailles dès le
départ on
dénombrait vous savez très bien que les
cinq premières formes plus grosses
fortunes de france oui non mais c'est
pas parce français s'est fait une vraie
sames là dessus c'est d'accord ce qui
est factuellement fausse et que nous
avons une caractéristique française
c'est une population non qualifiés donc
dont le travail est très sensible à son
cou et qui est par exemple deux fois
celle de l'allemagne pour des raisons
qui tiennent à l'inefficacité passé de
nos systèmes scolaires et nous avons un
coût du travail même avec les détaxation
qu'on a faits au niveau du smic est
supérieur à ce qu'on a encore 20 à 30%
de charges sont pas les salahi sont ces
cas difficiles
vous mettez l'on réussira pas d'accord
et c'est pas tout à fait un débat même
si évidemment on est sur le fond sur le
coût du travail en france je vous
propose d'entendre parce que cette
affaire c'est hubert files c'est du pain
béni pour l'opposition une critique
signé du président du rassemblement
national jordan bardella pour lui
emmanuel macron
van la france à l'étranger aulas qui
déclare les français ont vu une pub plus
que depuis dix ans dans notre pays
emmanuel macron est devenue le point
d'entrée d'intérêts privés d'intérêt
parfois étrangers et participe de ce que
olivier marleix qui s'appelle les
liquidateurs emmanuel macron a passé dix
ans à vendre l'industrie france
laure salvaing ont il ya une coalition d
opposition autour d'un dans une affaire
comme celle-là c'est c'est une
opportunité qui était trop belle pour ne
pas être saisi m'aider c'est assez
intéressant parce qu'il ya des arguments
de jordan bardella qu'on va entendre
aussi dans la bouche de député ou de
leader de la france insoumise devenu
tout à fait là je pense qu'effectivement
c'est c'est une brèche dans laquelle il
est facile de s'insérer et notamment
parce qu'on a eu aussi maclean's et
juste avant donc ça sera ajouté
effectivement un certain nombre de
dossiers d'affaires qui voilà qui qui
qui trouble un peu l'opinion je pense
dans l'image qu'ils ont du président la
république c'est à dire effectivement
qu'est ce qu'il défend et ça je pense
que depuis le départ et depuis notamment
son premier mandat le sens de la
politique d' emmanuel macron est pas si
clair que ça oui quand on interroge les
français et ça pas vraiment vers ouvert
où il veut aller y'a quand même cette
dimension de jeu veut casser les codes
pour pouvoir faire autrement
différemment et donner la chance aussi à
d'autres personnes et d'autres acteurs
voilà donc c'est aussi une illustration
malgré tout de cette politique alors je
voulais qu'on consacre plus de temps à
l'analyse du fonds avant de parler de la
forme et de cette petite référence à
jacques chirac je vais pas citer pour la
troisième fois la halle la formule
laetitia alors moi je vais vous dire
comment moi je le ressens je trouve que
c'est en terme de communication
politique assez bien joué parce que ça
ça ouvre une sorte de de contre-feux et
surtout ça va marquer une partie de
l'opinion occasion bon bah en fait
emmanuel macron ce il en a rien à je
vais être poli rien à faire le de ses
doigts seul et pour faire passer ce
message la référence à la formule de
jacques chirac était bien trouvé oui
alors c'est là où en fait c'est une
maladresse cette formule a déjà chirac
pourquoi parceque il l'emploie contre la
nuque et non pas concernant über en fait
c'est dans sa réponse il dit que la
nuque finalement a raté sa cible qu'elle
ne s'occupe pas de ces jeunes de
banlieue dont lui s'est occupé sans dire
cette affaire
ça fait cinq ans et demi que la nuque et
contre lui et donc il en a l'habitude et
l'utilisent cette péniche line on
l'appelait pas à l'époque comme cela de
jacques chirac voilà donc c'est vrai
qu'on en attendant c'est toujours un
amalgame et le tout et tous les médias
ont focalisé sur cette prime voilà
pourquoi c'est une maladresse et c'est
une erreur de communication parce que on
va focaliser sur cette pêche times en
oubliant le reste et on a comprenant mal
mais il me semble que ça allume un
contre-feu quand même le débat le débat
que nous avons eu la l'instant je trouve
que c'est vraiment ça sous tend tout
tout tout tout cette sortie des manuels
macron cette communication de crise
parce que vous avez deux systèmes ici
qui s'opposent deux idéologies de façon
de concevoir la politique et le bien
commun totalement opposés et quand on
dit le clivage gauche-droite a disparu
bien écoutez là on a eu une illustration
d'un clivage gauche droite et il me
semble que on l'a complètement c'était
une façon de
vous avez vous défendez la politique de
droite dément également avoir écouté
c'est la politique du de la social
démocratie scandinave c'est la politique
de la social démocratie allemande c'est
un débat qui traverse la gauche depuis
20 ans entre une mouche de protestation
une gauche d'opposition une gauche
tribunicienne une gauche radicale et une
gauche de transformation une gauche de
réformes une gauche qui a démontré son
succès de transformer en jeu
nous avions vous et moi je me sens pas
le défenseur de macron mais l'idée qu'
il faille par exemple transformer
favoriser le travail
la redistribution ça n'est pas du tout
une politique
de communication à part des manuels
macron parce que le vrai débat est là il
est dans le fond il n'est pas dans la
formule de jacques chirac est encore une
fois est un peut-être un écran de fumée
mais qui est malade dans l'opinion lors
salvat est ce que c'est cette formule
qui va marquer en fait moi je dirais
quand même quelque chose je pense qu'on
a beaucoup reproché aussi à emmanuel
macron ne pas être assez proche du
peuple de m de ne pas être justement en
proximité avec la population et je crois
qu'il a assez c'est peut-être pas une
erreur c'est peut-être un coup politique
justement qu'il a voulu jouer et
peut-être préparer justement en dise oh
mais finalement j'ai peut-être emprunter
à celui qui des présidents qui était bas
qui apparaît c'est en tout cas comme le
plus sympathique le plus proche de la
population etc et je vais un peu essayé
de faire comme lui à part que là ça
sonne un peu faux et surtout dans la
dans le la situation actuelle on n'avait
vraiment pas besoin de ce genre
d'expression de données olivennes on se
souvient que jacques chirac
effectivement inventé souvent une
formule quand d'ailleurs quand ils
étaient attaqués sur des affaires il y
avait eu le
abracadabrantesque qui avait eu ça fait
pschitt enfin c'est on est dans cette
lignée là oui mais si j'étais
psychanalyse dirais que c'est plutôt une
dénégation
il dit que ça ne touche pas mais je
construis elle touche et d'ailleurs on
voit qui est énervé on voit qu'il est
tendue on voit cette n'attaque il touche
et d'ailleurs je comprends ça le touche
parce que au fond c'est je reviens à ce
quizz et tout à l'heure il a été
l'avocat il a plaidé pour une certaine
libéralisation qui pensait qu'elle était
source de progrès et on l'accuse d'avoir
été l'agent de l'étranger
l'agent du capitalisme mondial un espèce
de figure cosmopolite et diabolisé et
donc ça ça doit le toucher quelque part
et je pense que c'est ça que cette
formule traduit ça m'en touche une sans
faire bouger l'autre à mon avis à lui en
touche
ni
les quatrièmes vous a choqué cette crue
mais non mais non je pense que d'abord
je pense qu'elle est totalement grossier
et vulgaire pour un présent de la
république franchement on n'a pas besoin
de ça on n'a pas envie de ça c'est le
premier point mais le deuxième point
c'est que en plus et je pense qu'il
comprend pas son époque c'est quand il
dit qu'il a déjà reçu nicolas hulot pour
discuter avec lui de savoir son
accusation de viol une discussion
d'homme à homme saaq ce qu'un certain
nombre de femmes et aujourd'hui qui vous
racontent ce que ça lui c'est du côté de
l'entrejambe et franchement on mettrait
sérieusement c'est d'un masculinisme
mais qui me sidère faire qu emmanuel
macron est entourée d'hommes et l'ami
maintenant
bornes premier ministre mais quand même
son univers est un univers hyper
masculins ils viennent de faire un
gouvernement hyper masculin et il
continue dans ses expressions
masculinistes franchement je trouve ça
mais il n'est pas bon il est pas de
fonte enfin paris des relais avec plus
de most important pour les états dits
déjà dix sur dix secrétaires d'état ne
forment les hommes sont ministres les
femmes sont secrétaires des palmes et
c'est pas ça bonjour ces vraiment
l'arrière plan culturel d'emmanuel
macron c'est un arrière-plan machiste
qui s'expriment dans des expressions le
circuit moi je peux employer une
expression comme celle là et je ne
publie non
takkal mais de nouveau
l'hypothèse d'une commission denquête
bonsoir quentin bienvenue plusieurs
groupes parlementaires d'opposition ont
appelé donc au lancement du commission
d' enquête sur cette affaire hubert
files voilà à chaque scandale à chaque
révélation un peu croustillantes et bien
sa proposition effectivement de
commission denquête au sénat ont ainsi
vu les sénateurs communistes chaude leur
expérience avec la ferme mckinsey en
appeler au président d'une
commission
ou theater commune pascal savall lieu
crois que le sénat a un patrimoine forme
de ce point de vue là du point de vue de
son utilité regardez ce travail sur la
commission d' enquête sur les
concessions autoroutières celui sur
l'hôpital et puis peut-être ce qui nous
les plus marquantes la sphère bénin ou
encore les cabinets privés les
sénatrices et des sénateurs au sénat ils
ont six missions de da poser des
questions débattre faire évoluer des
lois mais aussi faire un travail
d'investigation
parce que ça c'est un travail d'intérêt
général les deux autres de goût des deux
groupes de gauche ont été également
partagé des communiqués dans ce sens
hier voyez les socialistes inquiet
estime qu'une commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale serait bienvenu pour faire
la lumière sur ce sujet grave il insiste
particulièrement sur le fait que c'est
au détriment de la protection des
travailleurs qui mènent une macro aurait
disrupt et je cite le communiqué
l'administration française enfin les
sénateurs écologistes ont également
rejoint ce mouvement parlant d'un
phénomène d'ampleur aux implications
multiples dont toute la lumière doit
être faite lors des groupes de gauche
qui sont minoritaires au sénat faut donc
la corde à majorité de droite pour
lancer une telle commission denquête
qu'en pensent les nerfs eh bien nous
sommes allés à la réunion regroupe 1
questionne tous les mardis matin au
sénat l'idée fait clairement débat
écouter rapidement deux sénateurs à
l'air à notre micro ce matin une pro
enquête l'autre qui préfère attendre une
nouvelle révélation sur hubert mérite
vraiment qu'on s'y penche et
probablement qu'on élargisse le champ on
peut regretter des interférences est ce
qu'il y a pour le moment de quoi faire
une commission d enquête parlementaire à
mon sens non voilà pour le relais a
l'air n'ont pas arrêté de décision ils
attendent pour en savoir davantage et
dernier point si la commission denquête
voit le jour elle devra de toute façon
se faufiler là sur une ligne de crête à
quoi de l'immunité présidentielle dont
bien sûr le présent et publique est
protégé par son statut dans la
constitution le président ne peut pas
faire l'objet d'une procédure judiciaire
ou administrative pendant la durée de
son mental alors la constitution est
moins clair sur le fait de pouvoir lui
demander de témoigner devant une
commission denquête écouter un
spécialiste qu'on a souvent essayé a
invité à ce plateau benjamin moral aux
vues de l'esprit du constituant il est
quand même plutôt évident que le
l'audition devant une commission
d'enquêté fait pas vraiment partie des
autres après j'ai garé là on est dans un
débat un petit peu un petit peu débris
qui traiterait doctrinal parce qu'en
réalité
si jamais le chef de l'état tandis que
le chef de daïra et qu'irresponsable
site de v
ne pas répondre à la convocation d'une
commission denquête et bien on ne
pourrait pas vraiment lui reprocher on
ne pourrait pas le contraindre à
répondre voilà un argument qui ne
refroidit pas du tout à la gauche
sénatoriale qui demandent donc cette
commission enquête sur le même en
enquêtant sur les faits et les
entourages du chef de l'état à l'époque
mise aux économies bien on pourrait
beaucoup apprendre merci beaucoup quand
un calme est pour pour tous ces
informations lors salvin
sur l'impact sur la popularité des
macros je voudrais vous entendre pour
peut-être conclure cette première cette
séquence autour d'eux d hubert fights il
est déjà dans une période un peu
difficile on n'a pas j'imagine que vous
n'avez pas pu encore
mesurer l'effet des uv reffle sur sa
popularité mais bon on peut imaginer que
ça ne m'arrange pas alors c'est assez
étrange parce que par exemple la ferme à
qinze et malgré tout elle avait pas eu
d'impact accord norme sur l'opinion sur
l'image globale des manuels macron si
vous voulez je crois que ses soutiens et
ce qui est qu'ils ont plutôt confiance
en lui se moquer un peu de cette
histoire parce que quelque part c'est
pas l'heure c'est pas l'heure quotidien
enfin il considérait ce n'est pas leur
affaire et ce qui était déjà critique à
l'égard d' emmanuel macron sa renforcé
leurs critiques lâche je pense que ça
devrait en tout cas à ce stade ça
devrait être approuvée à peu près la
méche mais la même chose parce que
pourquoi en fait la préoccupation
principale aujourd'hui dépensées c'est
quand même vraiment pas ça oui je crois
que quand on voit notamment les journaux
télévisés les reportages etc on voit
bien quand même que la france a est en
souffrance et de plus en plus notamment
sur le pouvoir d'achat et que certes il
faudra régler il faudra éclaircir ces
histoires mais peut-être pas là tout de
suite d'autant plus que ça risque de
faire pschitt un peu comme la motion de
censure à l'égard des d'elisabeth bornes
qui en fait finalement cette motion de
censure le peu de pâte de pala ne pas la
voter ben ça ça a joué un peu al'inverse
c'est-à-dire salaces à la légitimité
quelque part auprès de l'assemblée
nationale donc faut faire attention aux
coups politiques qu'on veut faire
surtout dans cette période où la
population française est quand même
et quand même fragilisé et ça il faut
quand même le prendre bien sûr
évidemment et on l'a souvent traités
dans cette émission je voudrais terminer
ce premier débat par l'autre actualité
politique de cette journée c'est
l'examen du projet de loi sanitaire
alors c'est peut-être électrique à
l'assemblée des huées venue d opposition
à la fois de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale et du
rassemblement national notamment qu'en
2012 la santé a pris la parole motion de
rejet qui avait été déposé par la france
insoumise et repoussé de peut regarder
le résultat de cette motion de rejet a
été voté par 174 députés contre 192 et
vous le voyez ce qui est intéressant de
noter c'est que cette motion elle a été
soutenue par 70 députés la france
insoumise et 73 députés du rassemblement
national ce qui n'a pas surpris sacha
ollier député renaissance de la vienne
président de la commission des lois il
dénonce la collusion anti-vaccins de
certains élus des deux extrêmement
l'écoutent
pour autant le vote unanime
d'amendements et l'adoption de ce texte
ne va pas occulter ce qui s'est passé en
commission main dans la main les
populistes ont connu ni contre eux et
vaccins n'hésitant pas à recourir à
propager de fausses informations je
réaffirme ici car la démocratie ne
saurait s'accommoder du mensonge non les
vaccins n'empêche pas les cas limités
contamination à la cobi 19 mai oui mille
fois oui les vaccins empêche de
contracter des formes graves les vaccins
réduire les hospitalisations soulage nos
systèmes de santé les vaccins sauvent
des vies
catherine tricot cette alliance
deux circonstances on peut dire ça comme
ça mais tout de même à alliance du
rassemblement national et de la et de la
nuque pour voter
cette motion de rejet ça vous gêne
en l'occurrence qui me gêne c'est le
sujet serge je suis pas d'accord avec le
vote qui a été enfin le vote des ailes
de la rfi et du rassemblement national
où je suis clairement pour la
vaccination est donc je ne partage pas
ce qu'ils ont dit en revanche c'est pas
très surprenant que ce soit le cas et ça
ne justifie pas de dire que ce sont les
populistes dire qu' il dise quelque
chose ils disent une opposition ne peut
pas être réduite à un groupe lo qui
seraient les extrêmes à gauche accepte
ma droite dans le même sac tout le monde
à la mer non parce que à l'assemblée
nationale il ya des députés qui viennent
avec un point de vue sur le monde et
qu'ils expriment je pense qu'il vaudrait
mieux changer de registre parce qu'on va
pas aller très très loin sur ce cheval
là mais denis olivennes ce ce cette
sorte de l'alliance de circonstance on
va les revoir d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant d'analyser les deux
stratégie d'opposition différente du
rassemblement national d'un côté et de
la nuque de l'autre mais on est vraiment
sûr de stratégie pour l'instant opposé
là c'est la première fois qu'ils votent
ensemble un texte mais enfin une motion
de rejet pour pour être précis et ça
mais elle est fille devant une qu'on
fasse appel à la nuque j'ai moins de
contradiction parce que eux-mêmes
s'était plaint du fait que
la gouvernement ne tenait que par ce par
l'abstention du rassemblement national
et voilà que tout à coup un vote de
concerts etc l'assemblée nationale sur
sur une motion de rejet donc moi je me
souviens de pierre mendès-france qui
avait refusé de comptabiliser les oies
communiste à l'époque dans la confiance
qui lui était accordée parce qu'on le
supposé être le la créature de moscou et
pour bien montrer qu'il était
indépendant il avait calculé sa
confiance sur le vote or communiste donc
la nuque je vais être confronté à ça
assez régulièrement est ce qu'elle
accepte ou pas de se coaliser avec le
rassemblement national qui est
officiellement son ennemi absolu contre
le gouvernement il ya quand même quelque
chose pour les collections qu'elle est
toute autre
et c'est intéressant on voir le la
stratégie ou le jeu du rassemblement
national laure salvaing puisque par
exemple jordan bardella annoncé que le
rn votre à la loi pouvoir d'achat ce qui
sera certainement pas le cas de la nuque
est-ce que cette opposition constructive
qui est la ligne de marine le pen depuis
depuis plusieurs semaines est ce qu'elle
peut quand même perturbé une partie de
l'électorat historique
2 du front national ou des lepénistes on
va dire ça comme ça alors le l'électorat
l'électorat historique oui historique
justement je suis pas sûr qu'ils soient
si nombreux que ça aujourd'hui et
l'électorat historique on a vu un et
c'est les dernières élections nous l'ont
montré quand on analyse le vote des
français en fait avec une commande ya
une porosité entre les électorats
une volatilité des électeurs à certains
et on avait parlé ici à certains
électeurs nous disant a encore quinze
jours de l'élection présidentielle
j'hésite entre quatre personnes
mélenchon et marine le pen notamment
donc voyez il ya un électorat là qui est
vraiment beaucoup plus composites et
beaucoup plus diversifiée en si je crois
qu'on a aussi un problème
en france
notamment sur la scène publique sur dans
le débat public et en tracteur aussi du
débat public sur la place qu'il faut
aborder au rassemblement national
sachant qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
faire abstraction du fait qu' il s'agit
de la deuxième force politique quand
même malgré tout du pays et je crois
qu'on a toujours du mal à savoir s'il
faut finalement être systématiquement
contre ou s'il faut commencer à avoir un
discours et sachant que c'est plutôt
l'opinion va plutôt dans ce sens là
l'opinion française aujourd'hui elles
considèrent de moins en moins que le
rassemblement national et même des
images par donc interrompre ya des
images qui concourent à cette
normalisation quand on voit sébastien
chenu qui sait son c'est son titre et
les vice présidents de l'assemblée
nationale et il a présidé une séance de
l'assemblée denis olivennes ce qui est
normal et donc là on est dans cette
banalisation finalement recherché par
marine le pen depuis des années c'est
clair que la stratégie de
dédiabolisation qui a porté ses fruits
d'ailleurs on va encore franchir une
nouvelle étape et qu'ils vont jouer que
les élus du rassemblement national vont
jouer cette image de notabilité à fond
parce que le risque des de s'allier une
partie de leur électorat le plus
extrémiste et sans comparaison avec le
bénéfice d'aller chercher un électorat
de droite traditionnelle qui lui
échappaient jusqu'à présent donc c'est
clair que son bassin de progression est
là mais je dois dire que le fait qu' il
y ait des désaccords de des coalitions
nuque et rennes tous atteints vote va
les aider va les aider parce que ça veut
dire que même la gauche et sa partie la
plus radicale est capable de voter et
ils vont dire voilà on est rentré dans
un jeu de politique tracasseries à
modeler d'un prix de la traditionnelle
le débat est censé être terminé à oui je
pense qu'ils sont je pense que marine le
pen va essayer de se noter billy's et et
corps en effet je pense que son
électorat traditionnel lui fait
confiance un peu ce qu'ils veulent c'est
on l'a jamais au pouvoir l'on va et et
c'est moi je pense qu'elle est
véritablement aux portes du pouvoir on
le disait déjà
bien trois mois et que là ce qui se
passe là avec cette notabilisation à mon
avis concours le problème c'est que la
nouvelle année problème inverse c'est
qu'elle a le problème d'une gauche qui
n'a plus la confiance des gens de gauche
et que donc ils sont obligé d'affirmer
que réellement ils sont en opposition
avec macron donc on est il ya 3 3
groupes qui ont des objectifs et des
enjeux qui sont différents et qui crée
bien des difficultés
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat très bientôt sur sur public sénat
deux nuls et on vous retrouve pour cette
nouvelle émission littéraire à la
rentrée ça sera quoi mais écoutez j'ai
toujours aimé les libre depuis longtemps
et christopher baldelli qui dirige votre
antenne le savait et donc il m'a proposé
une demi heure par semaine de venir
vanter les mérites de deux ouvrages
soient de littérature ce que j'adorais
soit des essais et pourquoi pas d'autres
choses de poésie par exemple c'est de la
gourmandise à silloner basse et la
demande et surtout le goût de faire
partager vous savez j'étais prof de
lettres à l'origine donc j'ai cessé
cette mission mais je vais la renouveler
autres un prof de lettres c'est
quelqu'un qui donne l'amour de la
littérature aux enfants je vais la
donner maintenant j'espère au zoo aux
téléspectateurs de public sénat bon je
vais en profiter pour tout ça me vient
maintenant routeone le dernier livre de
michel moutot magnifique c'est
l'histoire de la construction de la
halle aux douanes aux états unis entre
los angeles et san francisco dans les
années 1930 merci encore à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat